[موسيقى]
مقابل كل شخص يعجب بك هناك تسعه على الاقل
لا يستسيغونك فلا تغتر بنفسك اذا اعرب
الكثيرون عن اعجابهم بك لان اكثر منهم
بكثير يحتشدون وبالملايين لمغنيه صدفه في
مكان اخر على اسوا كلمات وابشع لحن وانكر
صوت واقصر تنوره
فعشقناعاتك ولا تسال عن اعجاب الناس بك
يقول الفضيل ابن عياض عليك بطريق الحق ولا
تستوحش لقله السالكين واياك وطريق الباطل
ولا تغتر بكثره الهالكين
الى العناوين
المنافس الابرز لاردوغان على رئاسه تركيا
يقول انا علوي
رئيس المكسيك يبيع الطائره الرئاسيه لبناء
مستشفيين للفقراء
بثلاث ساعات يوتيوبر قطري يبني مدينتين
للنازحين في سوريا واليمن
قيس الخزعلي يقول ان اصول صدام حسين هنديه
من يبحث عن بيت ابي جهل في شوارع مكه
المكرمه
القروض بالقرود مئه الف قرد يسددون ديون
سريلانكا للصين
هل انتشر الاسلام بالسيف وسفك الدماء كريم
الشاذلي يجيب
[موسيقى]
مرحبا تدين الغالبيه العظمى من الشعب
التركي بدين الاسلام وهم على المذهب
الحنفي من اهل السنه والجماعه لكن الدستور
الذي اشرف على وضعه وتعديلاته اول رئيس
للجمهوريه التركيه مصطفى كمال اتاتورك بعد
انهيار السلطنه العثمانيه ينص بوضوح على
منع تشكيل اي حزب سياسي يعلن تمثيله لاي
شكل من اشكال المعتقد الديني دون ان يحضر
بالطبع اي انتماء دينيا شخصي
للسياسيين كمال كليتش دار اوغلو رئيس
الحزب الجمهوري الاتاتركي والمرشح الرئاسي
لطاوله الاحزاب المعارضه السته والمنافس
الابرز لاردوغان وصفته الصحف التركيه بانه
كسر احدى محرمات تركيا العلمانيه
الاتتركيه
باعلانه عن انتمائه الديني حيث قال في
فيديو للناخبين انا علوي ننتقل الى صحيفه
القدس العربي اعتراف النادر لزعيم
المعارضه الرئيسي في تركيا انا علوي
والنظام تمييزي في عهد الرئيس اردوغان
وذلك في احدث محاولاته للحصول على دعم
قبيل خوضه الانتخابات في الشهر المقبل
والتنافس امام الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغانم
وزير الداخليه المقرب من اردوغان سليمان
سويلو يتهم كليتش داروغل بانه بكلامه عن
طائفته يحاول تقديم نفسه كضحيه وقال قبل
اردوغان لم يكن احد ليجرا على قول هذه
الكلمه في تركيا اما الان فالكل اصبح يقول
ما يريده وبكل حريه رئيس حزب تركيا
المستقله حسين باش اراد ان يهين اردوغان
فاهان منافسه في الانتخابات عندما قال
سنصوت لمنافس اردوغان حتى لو كان نعال
مرحاض تورته
ارجو من كارسن
جنابه
لاحظ الاعلام الاوروبي ان توقيت تعهد
اردوغان بتوفير الغاز مجانا للمنازل ولمده
عام كامل ياتي قبيل الاقتراعي للانتخابات
الرئاسيه
انها خطوه تاريخيه على طريق اكتفاء البلاد
ذاتيا من الطاقه عند بلوغ الانتاج الحد
الاقصى فان الغاز المستخرج من البحر
الاسود سيغطي قرابه 30% من حاجه تركيا
السنويه كمال كليتش داروغلو كان اذكى من
كل المرشحين فباعهم الشمس وعد الناخبين
بان الشمس ستوفر لهم الكهرباء مجانا وقد
تفائل المزارعون الاتراك بان يتعاون القمر
ايضا بتقويه مستوى الاضاءه ليلا
[موسيقى]
الله يجري شمال
في الوعود الانتخابيه ايضا لكن في المكسيك
بعض الرئيس اندريس لوباز اوبرادور قبل خمس
سنوات اثناء حملته الانتخابيه وعد
الناخبين بانه سيعرض طائره الرئاسه للبيع
اذا فاز ليبني بثمنها مستشفيين في الجنوب
المكسيكي الاكثر فقرا في البلاد الوعد
ببيع الطائره مطار لكن الزبونه تاخر قليلا
وقد حضر الان
كستان اشترت الطائره والف مبروك
المستشفيين لجنوب المكسيك وعقبال
المبادرات منها النوع لكل الشعوب الفقيره
اوبرادور من البعد الانتخابي الى البر
بالوعد
ومن سولته
[موسيقى]
بثلاث ساعات فقط من البث المباشر بنى
مواطن قطري مدينتين للنازحين في سوريا وفي
اليمن فقد اعلن اليوتيوبر عبد الله
الغافري عن جمع ما يقارب عشره ملايين
دولار خلال حمله الرمضانيه بعنوان تحدي
ليله السابع والعشرين الحمله تمت باشراف
مؤسسه قطر الخيريه التي ستشرف ايضا على
بناء مدينه الكرامه في سوريا ومدينه الخير
ات في اليمن لاواء اكثر من عشره الاف نازح
في مساكن كريمه تشمل الاستجابه الطبيه
الطارئه والمعونه الغذائيه والمياه والصرف
الصحيه والنظافه والمساعدات الماليه
حلوين حلوين حلوين جاهزين جاهزين له الرقم
اللي كلنا نبي كم الرقم
صح احنا الحكم وصلنا 29 مليون
و391,256 صح جاهزين
باقي ست دقايق باقي ست دقايق نعم واقوى
تبرع من بدينا البرنامج
تتبرع واحد تتبرع واحد لدفعه واحده
مليونين ريال قطري
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله الحمد لله الحمد لله في مقابل
التعاون الايجابي على ايجاد حلول تدعم
المحتاجين ينطلق النائب المغربي محمد
السيمو من الضائقه الاقتصاديه بسلبيه
ثقيله ليطالب حكومه بلاده بالغاء عيد
الاضحى المبارك تحت زريعه ان الفقراء لا
يستطيعون شراء الاضاحي ولوازم العيد وقد
غاب عن فهم النائب ومستوى تعليمه ان العيد
مناسبه دينيه تعبديه تبدا بالصلاه وتنتهي
بصله الرحم مرورا بسنه الاضاحي التي
يقدمها الاغنياء للفقراء اما لوازم بهجه
العيد فالحديث الشريف يقول من نفس عن مؤمن
كربه من كرب الدنيا نفس الله عنه كربه من
كرب يوم القيامه
فبدل ان تحجب العيد عن الفقراء عزيزي
النائب السيمو حل كيسك او حل عنه يعني
تبرع بمقدورك وادعوا الى التبرع ولا تتحدث
فيما ليس لك به علم
قناتي
من الصعب العيدان المباركان محفوظان لا
تلغيهما حكومه ولا امم متحده كذلك القران
الكريم فان حفظه ليس متوقفا على ضمانه احد
من المسلمين فالله تعالى تعهد بحفظ قرانه
الكريم وعلى الرغم من تراجع المسلمين
اليوم الا ان عدد حفاظ القران في ازدياد
دائم ومن مختلف البلاد والتخصصات والاعمار
الحافظ الصغير عبد الله طفل ابهر لجنه
الاختبار في الازهر
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله اسم عبد الله جه
في القران
في سوره ايه
[موسيقى]
هل صحيح ان صدام حسين هندي فقط بثت قناه
تلفزيونيه مقربه من زعيم فصيل العصائب في
العراق قيس الخزعلي خطابا للخزعلي اثار
جدلا واسعا يقول فيه ان تحليل الحمض
النووي للرئيس صدام حسين اثبت انه ينحدر
من اصول هنديه كما كان يدعي
صدام الهدام عندما اتهم
سكان هذا البلد الاصليين بانهم جاؤوا من
الهند ثم بعد ذلك عندما قاموا
بتحليل ديان اي مالتها تبين انه هو الذي
جاء من الهند بكل الاحوال الهند ستتربع
على عرش الديموغرافيا وستصبح اكبر دوله في
العالم من حيث عدد السكان وفق بيانات
حديثه للامم المتحده حيث ستتجاوز الهند
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه بنحو ثلاثه ملايين
نسمه بحلول منتصف العام الجاري لكن وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه
تكشف ان الهند لم تقم باي احصاء لسكانها
منذ عام 2011 لذلك هي لا تملك الارقام
الحقيقيه والرسميه عن عدد السكان المقدر
في البلاد ثبوت تهمه التدبر على الموظفين
كانت كافيه في لندن للاطاحه بناء برئيس
الوزراء البريطاني دوميني كراب فيما مسؤول
صغير في بلد عربي
اغلبيه مواطنيه بالمتخلفين ولا احد يستقيل
او حتى يعتذر بعد ذلك
نائب رئيس الوزراء يجبر على الاستقاله
بعدما كشف تحقيق مستقل استغرق خمسه اشهر
انه كان يمارس سلوكا عدوانيا على نحو
مستمر وغير مبرر تجاه موظفي كما كشف
اساءته للسلطه خلال تقلده مناصب حكوميه
عديده ادرك انني ارتكبت اخطاء خلال اربع
سنوات ونصف لكن السؤال هو هل تصل هذه
الاخطاء الى مستوى التنمر اعتقد بشده انه
اذا كانت عتبه التعريف بالتنمر تصل الى
مستوى تنبيه الموظفين الى الاخطاء فسيؤدي
هذا في النهايه الى ان يدفع الناس ثمن هذه
الاخطاء عندما يذهب الحاج او المعتمر الى
اراضي الحرمين الشريفين يتلمس خطوات
الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام ومسجده وبيته
لكن لا احد يخطر في باله البحث عن بيت ابي
جهل زعيم كفار قريش حصل ذلك مع هذا
المعتمر من يبغى
[موسيقى]
عمود
مدينه منوره ما في
لكن ما يدرينا بمراد الاخ من زياره بيت
ابي جهل ربما افتقد في بعض عروبتنا
الحاليه مروءه عروبه الجاهليه دايما بقول
للناس عباره كده
نبقى حاليا عندنا اخلاق كفار قريش ولما
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ربنا نجاه منهم
في الهجره فكروا ان هم يقتحموا بيت النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم فالسيده فاطمه جوه قال
لهم لهم لا اوعوا ابو جهل اشد الاعداء قال
لها
تعيرنا العرب باننا افزعنا بنات محمد
الكره والاحترافيه تركلها قدم من جسمه
سليم اما الاخلاق الرياضيه فتنبع من العقل
السليم موقف جديد يضم الى قائمه افضل
مواقف الروح الرياضيه في تاريخ كره القدم
هجمه مرتده وهدف يتراقص امام اللاعب
النرويجي بارد فين
فيتعفف عنه بعد تعرض منافسه سوندري سول
هلم لاصابه اثناء مطاردته وذلك خلال
منافسات الدوريه النرويجي الممتاز لكره
القدم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
البعض يتعمد ان يكسر الكاس ويسكب اللبن كي
يمارس هوايته في البكاء على اللبن المسكوب
تقول الكاتبه شهرزاد الخليج اما مهرجان
سومو لبكاء الاطفال
فيحيي هوايه ومقوله يابانيه غريبه تعتبر
ان الاطفال الذين يبكون كثيرا ستكون صحتهم
جيده عندما يكبرون في مهرجان
يفوز الطفل الشاكي الباكي في حضن اهله قبل
الطفل المنافس له وكلما على صراخه ارتفعت
قيمته
[موسيقى]
سريلانكا تملك فائضا من القرود تتلف
الكثير من محاصيلها الزراعيه اما الصين
فتحتاج هذه القرود لتملا بعض الحدائق بها
كما تقول
فتمل الاتفاق بين الطرفين على تسديد
القروض بالقرود مئه الف قرد سيسددون عن
سريلانكا ديونها للصين وفد صيني يطالب
وزير الزراعه السيرلنكي بسداد بعض ديون
بلادهم من خلال ارسال مئه الف قرد الى
الصين الصين تريد القرود من فصيله المكاك
لنقلها الى حدائق الصين وسط تخوفات كبيره
من استخدام هذه القرود لاغراض طبيه تعاني
سيرلانكا ايضا من ارتفاع اعداد القرود في
اراضيها والتي تنمو بسرعه وقد تصل اعدادها
الى نحو ثلاثه ملايين قرد وهو عدد كبير
يشكو منه المزارعون باستمرار بسبب تضرر
محاصيلهم هل كنتم تتخيلون حجم الخساره
الحضاريه للبشريه لو منع هذا الشاب من
تحويل نفسه الى شكل شيطان في البرتغال
احتفلت موسوعه جينيس بغرسه ثلاثه وثلاثين
قرنا في راسه توسلا لمظهر يبديه كالشيطان
وابو قرون كمان
البرتغال حطم ميشيل برادو والرقم القياسي
لعدد قرون السيليكون الموجوده على راس
بشري بتجاوزه ثلاثه 33 قرنا ليدخل بذلك
موسوعه غينيس ولتحقيق ذلك اضطر برادو
لاجراء تعديلات عده على جسده كشق لسانه
الى نصفين وقطعي انته وغرس اسنان معدنيه
ليبدو اقرب شكلا للشيطان
انتعلوا احذيه النسائيه للتضامن مع النساء
فقالت لهم امراه كنديه الضبضب واسترجلوا
نريد ذكورا تحترمنا ونحترمها ولا نريد
متشبهين من الرجال بالنساء في بادره لدعم
حقوق النساء انقلبت عليهم غضبا من النساء
انتعل سياسيون كنديون كعبا نسائيا عاليا
ورديا اللون
وتمايلنا به امام الكاميرات وقد اعتبروا
ان ذلك يشجع الرجال والشباب الذكور على ان
يكونوا جزءا من الحل لكن ماذا عن النساء
الكنديات هل اعجبتهن الفكره
احداهن تقول هذه صفعه على وجه كل امراه
فلم ارتدي حذاء ورديا في حياتي ولسنا
بحاجه الى رجال مؤنثين يتجولون بالكعب
العالي واعتبرت اخرى ان الخطوه لا تعدو
كونها تهريجا من مهرجين وهجمت وزير النقل
الكنديه عمر الغبره الذي كان من ابرز
المنظمين لفعاليه الكعب الاحمر اخيرا لا
تياس فلا بد ان يشرق الضوء في اخر النفق
يقول المثل الفنلندي اذا شعرت بانك تتقدم
في العمر ولم تنجز امورا هامه بعد في
الحياه فهذه مقدمه برامج بودكاست في عقدها
الرابع توصلت من كم يوم بس الى اكتشاف
مبهر وهو ان اسماء الاسبوع مرتبطه
بالارقام احد واحد اثنين اثنين تخيلوا
كم كان عمركم عندما عرفتم هذا السر الخطير
كنا عم نحكي مع رفقاتنا كنت عم بقول انه
انا اكتشفت انه قسم الاسبوع تبعين لارقام
يعني احد واحد اثنين اثنين ثلاثه
طلعوا في وقالوا لي نحن ما بحياتنا
انتبهنا هذا الموضوع قلت لهم لانه انتم
حفظتوا بالمدرسه كانوا ايه
[موسيقى]
ختاما
ركز بعض المستشرقين على فكره ان الاسلام
انتشر بحد السيف ورفض البعض الاخر هذا
التوجه وتحدثوا عن ان الجهاد كان لحمايه
الدعوه الى الاسلام ورد العدوان في محاضره
له عام 2006 وصف الباب الراحل بندكتوس
السادس عشر الاسلام بانه انتشر عن طريق
اراقه الدماء واستشهد بحديث رجل فارسي
لاحد اباطره البيزنطيين حيث قال له لن تجد
في الاسلام غير الشر مثل امره بنشر الدين
بحد السيف الكاتب المصري كريم الشاذلي
يقول نعم لقد انتشر الاسلام بالسيف لان
الفكره تحتاج الى قوه تمنع محاصرتها لكن
السيف لم يفتح القلوب التي اعتنقت الاسلام
فبقيت عليه عندما انهزم المسلمون
الى اللقاء مستحيل الاسلام كان ينتشر الا
بالعين الحمراء راجل عنده 40 سنه
مفيش في سيرته خدش
لدرجه ان كان اسم الشهره بتاعه الصادق
الامين
فجاه خليتوه كداب وساحر ومجنون وصاحب
اجنده حط فوقهم 12 سنه كمان عايش فيهم وسط
ناس ظلمه
بيتعرضوا له في الرايحه والجاية بيعتدوا
عليه وهو بطوله اتعذبوا اصحابه بتحاصروا
فكرته كان ايه طلبه ايه جمله واحده بس طلب
واحد بس خلوا بيني وبين الناس
عندي كلمتين عايز اقولهم للناس
سيبوني اقول للناس فكرتي خايفين ليه عمره
صلى الله عليه وسلم رفض اي دعوه لحوار
12 سنه لا عارف يصلي في امان ولا يقابل
الوفود اللي جايه تحج ولا يرفع صوته
ولما فرض عليكم امر واقع
جايين النهارده تقولوا انه نشر رسالته
بالسيف والعنف
عزيزي المغفل السيف ممكن يفتح بلد بس عمره
ما يفتح قلب اجدادك الغزاه احتلوا المنطقه
عقود وسنين وخرجوا زي ما دخلوا سرقونا
ونهبونا ورسموا حدود وقعتنا في بعض عدي
على المغرب والجزائر وتونس وليبيا ومصر
والشام وهات لي واحد اتفتن باخلاء
العصابات اللي جاتنا ما فيش قوه مهما كان
تقدر تنشر فكره
بس الفكره لو معهاش قوه
تتحاصر من اول ما قابيل استخدم العنف
والموضوع بقى واضح ما فيش حق بيعيش علشان
هو حق والموفه بس اللي يقف قدام الدبابه
ورد ولو في دماغك بربع درهم عقل كنت تبص
للسيف لما انتصر عمل ايه
النبي دخل مكه اللي فضلت سنين تؤذيه دخلوا
معه عشر الاف سيف مرفوعه مستنيه اشاره منه
عشان تشفي الغليل غليل عمار وبلال وتاخد
حق سميه وياسر وحمزه وغيرهم اللي رمل مكه
يشهد على اللي حصل فيهم لكنه طمن القلوب
المرعوبه ادى الناس قال لهم براءه براءه
اذهبوا فانتم الطلقاء وخلصت الكلام خلاصه
الكلام السيف ممكن يفتح بلد لكن الفكره
الفكره الصح الفكره اللي ماسكه نفسها بس
هي اللي تقدر تفتح القلوب وهات لي دوله
واحده دخلها الاسلام بالقوه ولما دار
الزمن وضعف اهلها ارتدوا مش المفروض انهم
كانوا مخصوبين
[موسيقى]